كيف ستحدد ما إذا كان
الإيرانيون جادون بشأن العودة إلى
المحادثات النووية كما أوضحوا
أنهم سيفعلون بحلول نهاية نوفمبر
وما هي التكاليف التي أنت على استعداد لفرضها على
إيران إذا استمرت في
شن هجمات ضد الولايات المتحدة
مثل  ضربات الطائرات بدون طيار الأخيرة ضد
القوات الأمريكية في سوريا
بشكل جيد بمعنى أن هناك مسألتان مختلفتان
أحدهما هو ما إذا كنا نصل إلى
jcpoa أم لا نعيد الانضمام إلى
ذلك وهذا يعتمد على السبب في أنني
عقدت اجتماعات مع زملائي هنا
في أه في روما.  جزء من
المجموعة الأصلية المكونة من ستة أشخاص ، الدول الست
التي اجتمعت لتقول إنه
يجب علينا التفاوض بشأن التغيير
الذي وجدت أنني أعتقد أننا ما زلنا
نعاني من الأحكام السيئة للغاية التي
أصدرها الرئيس ترامب وانسحب من حكومة اليابان.
ولذا فهذه مشكلة واحدة وستعتمد هذه
المشكلة على ما إذا كان سيتم
حلها وكيفية حلها سيعتمد على
تصرفاتهم واستعداد
أصدقائنا الذين يشكلون جزءًا من الأصل.
اتفاقية نهائية للبقاء معنا والتأكد من
وجود ثمن يدفعه اقتصاديًا
لفشلهم في العودة
فيما يتعلق بمسألة
كيفية ردنا على الإجراءات
التي يتخذونها ضد المصالح في الولايات المتحدة
سواء كانوا  ضربات الطائرات بدون طيار أو
أي شيء آخر سنرد عليه وسنواصل الرد